abril el mes más letal para los
defensores de Derechos Humanos en
Colombia Lenin Jaime Diana Luisa son
algunos de los nombres de los 21 líderes
sociales asesinados por su ejercicio de
Liderazgo social en territorio pero
también en las ciudades hemos
documentado 21 asesinatos de Defensores
de derechos humanos y otros líderes
sociales ocurridos en el mes de abril
esa cifra más alta en lo que va del año
en total hemos documentado 55 asesinatos
de Defensores y líderes sociales en
Colombia según Frontline defenders
Colombia representó el 48% de los 186
asesinatos documentados y verificados en
la región de las Américas durante 2022
un conteo diario de muertes de líderes
masacres y persecución a los firmantes
del acuerdo de paz con la guerrilla de
las FARC al menos 358 es guerrilleros
asesinados desde 2016 y unas altas tasas
de impunidad una reciente investigación
de dicha organización apunta a las
causas de esta violencia la falta de
presencia Estatal integral en los
municipios y regiones más afectadas por
la violencia social y política hacen que
el principal factor de riesgo continúe
siendo la generación de disputas
económicas y políticas de la mano con la
existencia organización y
fortalecimiento de estructuras legales e
ilegales Mientras que el presidente
Gustavo Petro está inmerso en los
diálogos para lograr la ambiciosa paz
Total que prometió en campaña una
realidad alejada de los territorios
golpeados por el control territorial de
grupos criminales y el narcotráfico